[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لن نهدى حتى تكسر اوكرانيا شوكه بوتين
اوروبا تخاطب بوتين وبوتين يرد سيكون لذلك
عواقب وخيمه وماريا زخرفه تجيب بسخريه فما
الذي يجري والذل المسكي يشعل النار في
صدور الروس وموسكو ترد لتطفئها ونيته يحذر
روسيا من اي تحركات عسكريه مريبه والشعب
الروسي يقول نعم
الصين تحذرنيته وتخترق بريطانيا داخل
اراضيها وبعد نشر العراق لجيشه ايران
تستنفر جيشها على الحدود فهل تندلع الحرب
ومئات الجنود الامريكان ينتشرون في سوريا
روسيا تتوسط نزاع اوروبا
على قدم وساق يمضي الاوروبيون ويجتمعون
لمعاقبه روسيا لكن هذه العقوبات تنعكس
عليهم بشكل سلبي فهل يجدون حلا لهذه
المشكله ليعلنها الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى
لسان رئيسه مفوضيه اننا لن نداى حتى تتغلب
اوكرا على بوتن وتنتهي حربه البربريه
بينما يعلن الاوروبيون عن حزمه تاسعه من
العقوبه ضد موسكو ولكن يبدو ان عقوبتهم
ستعدهم عليهم هذه المره ايضا ايضا واخفق
وزراء طاقه الاوروبيون في الاتفاق على
تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط والغزل الروسي
بسبب الخلافات التي تدور بينهم ليصدر بوتن
مرزوما رسميا بعدم تصدير النفط والغاز
للدول التي وضعت للاسعار قائلا سيكون لذلك
عواقبنا خيمه على اسواق الطاقه ليتدخل
الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن ويؤكد ان مقترحه
واشنطن وحلفائها بشان تحديد سقف باسعار
نفط الروسيه لا يزال قائما ولكن مهلا في
امريكا لا تستورد الغزل من اوروبا الى
بنسبه قد لا تتجاوز الخمسه عشر بالمئه
وهذه نسبه طويله جدا هنا خلاف الاوروبيين
يستمر لتشهد بروكسل الاجتماعي لوزاره
الداخليه
بشان المهاجرين والاحتواء التوتر بين
فرنسا وايطاليا بسبب هذه القضيه وبالعوده
الى اوكرانيا منظمه الصحه العالميه
التابعه للامم المتحده حذرت منك كارثه
انسانيه في اوكرانيا بسبب الشلل الذي اصاب
شبكه الكهرباء
من قبل القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانه ينتظرون شتاء صعبا هنا امريكا
ترفع اصبعها لتهدد حيث حضرت المندوبه
الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده من تسرب
اشعاعين في اوكرانيا ليخرج مندوب روسيا
الامم المتحده فازلي ويقول ان بلاده توجه
ضربات باسلحه دقيقه للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه
التي تستخدم لاغراض عسكريه وانه اوكرانيا
تضرب بنيه التحتيه بنفسها وتحاول اتهام
روسيا ليجتمع بوتا بامهات جنود الحرب
وزوجتهم ويحذر بانه هناك معلومات
ترويجها عن العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وخلال ذلك وصل 35 جنديا من القوات الروسيه
الى شبه جزيره القرنه في عمليه تبادل
للاسرى مع القوات الاوكرانيه تخرج
بريطانيا معلنه عن ساعده جديده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه ثمانيه ملايين جنيه استرليني لتوفير
احتياجات الشتاء روسيا تشعل فتيل السخريات
بعد ان صوتت اوروبا لاعتبار روسيا دوله
راعيه للارهاب المتحدثه الرسميه باسم
روسيا ماريا زخروف ترد ساخره اقتراح
الاعتراف بالبرلمان الاوروبي كراع للحماقه
زخرف تعود مجددا وترد على الزوجه زرتك
بشان استطلاع قدره الشعبي على التحمل
قائله ثم اجراء استطلاع الرايه على ما
يبدو في قلبه تتساقط كره الثلج بانتظام
بينما اعلنت بلا روسيا على لساني سفيرها
في الامارات انها تقف مع موسكو ولكنها لم
تشترك في الحرب فالحان وقت الوقوف مع
الحليب الروسي خصوصا ان الحدود البلا
روسيه تتعرض لها جامعه متبادله مع الجاره
الاوكرانيه ليعلنها الشعب الروسي نعم
لبوتين وذلك في استطلاع للراي اجره مركز
ابحاث الراي العام لعموم روسيا وبنحوه 88
فاصله سبعه في المائه صوته بثقه
بينما اثار التصريحات
غضب روسيا اذ شدد الرئيس الاوكراني ان حل
الازمه لابد ان يشمل شبه جزيره القرد
موسكو
لا يريد خلل الازمه بالطرق السياسيه ويبحث
عن الطرق العسكريه لتعلن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تصفيه اكثر من 30 100 جندي اجنبيه
غالب من بولندا
مواقعهم في
مقاطعهم لتطالبه حكومه عند المانيا بارسال
قاذفه صواريخ باتريوت لاوكرانيا ومن لندى
الى الامم المتحده التي قالت ان مقاطع
الفيديو التي تظهر اعدام اسرع حرب الروسي
اوكرانيا من المرجح جدا ان تكون حقيقيه
وفقا لم ذكرت وكاله رويترز وهنا الامين
العام لحلف الناتو الحلف سيدير الدفع
للقيال اي هجوم او موقف عدوانيه ضد السويد
او فنلندا الصين تتلاعب بالاستغبارات
البريطانيه
دائما في الوقت والمكان المناسبين فيه
اراضي خصومهم هنا الحكومه البريطانيه تامر
بازاله جميع كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه
واستبدالها باخرى لانها تخضع للاستخبارات
الصينيه وذلك حسب ما افاد المتحدث باسم
الحكومه البريطانيه ههه اين ستهربون فكل
شيء صنعت الصين ليخرج المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه شاولين بتصريح شديد
اللهجات انهم يتعين على حلف ايتو البقاء
الداخل حدوده الجغرافيه وعدم متجاوز سلطه
الحلف من خلال فرض قواعد الخاصه على الدول
الاخرى كما يحاول ان يفعل منذ نهايه الحرب
البارده نعم هنا بكين تقترب من تقويل بحر
الصين الجنوبي الى ملاذ لغواصاتها التي
تحمل صواريخ البالستيه والرؤوس النبويه
التي بامكانها الوصول للاراضي الامريكيه
وهذا يعتبر تهديدا لم يكن موجودا من قبل
ذلك بحسب تصريحه قياده الاسطول الامريكيه
في المحيط الهادي
الاحداث والتطورات
بعد ان قرر العراق نشر جنودي على الحدود
مع ايران ارسل الحرس الثوري الايراني
مدرعات الى حدود العراق بعد ان هدد
بالقيام بعمليه عسكريه ضد الاحزاب الكرديه
المعارضه الايراني
من بغداد والمجتمع الدولي القوات
الامريكيه تنتشر فتنتين وعشرين قاعده
عسكريه وتغطي معظم حقول النفط ويبلغ عدد
قواتها 900 جندي في سوريا اسباب مركز جسور
للدراسات كافه سلاح الجو التركي على مناطق
شمال سوريا وفد امريكي يلتقي بقيادته
سوريا الديمقراطيه لبحث التهدئه مع تركيا
الفيفا يقول انه خلال الفتره المتبقيه من
مونديال قطر 2022 لم يتم ايقاف المشجعين
الذين يرضون شعار المثليه من قبل موظفي
امن الملاعب بحصبي صحيفتي اندبندنت
البريطانيه عندما اجتمع الاوروبيون
لمعاقبه روسيا اصبحوا هم المعاقبين وكثره
الخلافه بينهم فماذا لو الغوت تلك
العقوبات
[موسيقى]